when I was a child I was fascinated by
telepathy in science fiction in fact I
tried really hard to read other people's
minds to project my thoughts into other
people's heads and I came to the
conclusion that maybe telepaths do walk
the surface of the earth but I wasn't
one of them now I'm a physicist and I
realized that with all the
electromagnetic probes that we have of
the human brain we can actually see
thoughts ricocheting across the brain
itself we can see the thinking living
brain as it thinks and we can create
computer simulations of this to
understand what people are thinking so
at the present time telepathy exists for
example look at my colleague Stephen
Hawking he's lost control of his fingers
now so he cannot communicate even with
the laptop computer but look at his
right frame of his glasses there's an
EEG sensor that picks up rain radio
waves from his brain decodes that and
he's allowed to manipulate to some
degree a laptop computer you can do
better by putting a chip directly on top
of the brain people who are totally
paralyzed who are vegetables and they're
trapped in this shell of a lifeless body
these people can now play video games
they can read email write email do
crossword puzzles they can operate their
wheelchair they can control household
appliances they can control mechanical
arms next they will control mechanical
legs and exoskeletons in fact one of the
people that pioneers this technology for
the next World Soccer Cup wants to have
a paralyzed person put on an exoskeleton
and initiate the soccer games that's a
goal for one of the scientists that I've
interviewed for my book
and so we're way past simply
understanding the way in which the brain
radiates radio we're at the point now
where we can actually interface the
human brain with a computer and
eventually with an exoskeleton by which
they can become Iron Man
and so Ironman is not simply a question
of science fiction it's something that
we can actually visualize in the
laboratory in addition to putting a chip
on top of the brain you can actually put
sensors directly into the brain itself
that are like hair like thin fibers
there's a certain class of people with
depression that have been resistant to
drugs
pharmacology psychiatry counseling they
are chronically depressed it turns out
that when you put a brain scan put them
in a brain scan you find out that yes
indeed there's a certain part of the
brain that seems to be associated with
this depression by putting in probes you
can dampen the electrical activity of
this and all of a sudden they're cured
on one hand you see somebody who's
chronically depressed wants to commit
suicide has been played by this and
afterwards they're just cured it's
remarkable but this is just another
other ways that we could access the
human mind another way is through probes
in an operation on epileptics epileptics
have many seizures
many of them are life-threatening it's
possible to remove part of the cranium
these people are fully awake during this
process cuz the skull has no sense
organs to sense pain you put a bunch of
electrodes directly on the brain itself
these people can type these people can
type very quickly simply by thinking
about it they think about a certain
letter a computer recognizes the pattern
and the computer will type in this way
yet another way of probing into the
brain itself
is with an MRI scan we can take the
living brain put it in an MRI and get
30,000 dots like a Christmas tree set of
lights that code the amount of
electrical activity you take these
30,000 dots put it into a computer
program that can then decipher it and
bingo which you get is a picture of what
they are thinking we can now visualize
what
somebody is thinking about in fact it's
on the web there's a picture of Steve
Martin for example in one of his movies
and then right next to it is the picture
as viewed through the human mind this is
amazing you can clearly recognize the
eyes the ears you cannot recognize the
fact that it's Steve Martin however you
can also do giraffes you can put
elephants and clearly you're looking at
an animal and not a human and now get
this we can actually begin the process
of photographing dreams this was
considered pure science fiction look at
the movie with Leonardo DiCaprio called
inception it turns out that the first
steps in this direction have been taken
already in Kyoto and at Berkeley what
you do is you put the patient in an MRI
scanner and he falls asleep the brain is
then scanned creating 30,000 dots a
computer analyzes the 30,000 dots of a
sleeping brain and reconstructs the
image of what he's dreaming about now
I've seen these pictures they're pretty
crude you see a picture of a human and
obviously he's thinking about and
dreaming about a human but one day we
may be able to refine this technique so
that when you wake up in the morning and
you hit the play button of a computer
you see the dream that you had last
night
you